last question today hey David if Trump
committed obvious certifiable undeniable
treason how quickly could he be removed
from office you know we probably like to
think that if the president does
something treasonous that's just over
the line and we'd be able to get them
out right away that's not really the way
it would work unfortunately I mean every
every process that exists for removing a
president has a massive bureaucratic
delay many would argue for better you
don't want it to be easy to remove a
president for merely political reasons
there really should be strong reasons
for doing that and I tend to agree with
that I mean it should be difficult to
remove a president the question is how
difficult and how quickly could the
system act if there was something very
clear that was over that line and
oftentimes we sort of think we'll hold
on if the evidence is so compelling that
there was treason it should be really
easy to remove the president the problem
with that pad is that you need a process
to determine what evidence counts as
compelling and there is really no way to
make that happen quickly removal of a
president under the 25th amendment would
take a while
impeachment proceedings which are
initiated by the house ultimately
adjudicated by a Senate vote requiring
two-thirds of senators to say remove the
president all of that stuff takes time
and we can be critical of that but you
do need that because otherwise the
system becomes liable to be misused or
corrupted yeah
treason such a loaded war word because I
think that requires you actually being
at war with a country and sort of aiding
and abetting the enemy which we're
probably not gonna find ourselves in in
2018 but I think people use treason as a
word to sort of wrap up the Trump Russia
collusion scandal that's going on and I
think even if definitive evidence came
out tying Trump and Putin that Putin
would try to help Trump's campaign
through election meddling through
spreading fake
and they had talked about it all along
if all that stuff came out and it was a
meta standard of evidence that even
those on the right would would say all
right this passes he definitely did
collude with the Russians still I don't
think you're gonna get those 67 senators
certainly you'd get all the Democrats
but are you gonna sway the 15 and 20 or
so that you would need from the
Republican side to get him out of office
I don't think so and that's why I think
over the next two years
impeachment from the house for one
reason or another it doesn't have to be
Russia it could be something else
possible but a conviction I think is
unlikely yeah I tend to agree with you I
you don't do the one thing is and you
did get to this you don't really need to
be at war treason is betraying of one's
country if the president has betrayed
the interests of the United States in
favor of the interests of some other
country that that would meet the
definition of treason but I agree with
you I mean it's a lot of this stuff it's
sort of like prosecuting perjury perjury
even if you can have sort of like
colloquial agreement about what happened
it is going to be extraordinarily
difficult to actually make it happen for
better or worse I know there will be
people who will write in and say David
it's bad that it's so difficult to
remove a president you know I I still
would be extraordinarily worried about
mechanisms through which a president
could be removed for merely political
reasons the Bill Clinton Fiasco comes to
mind he ultimately was not removed
although he was impeached and so I think
it's important for it to be difficult
removing a president is very very
serious what you have to remember is
that maintaining the integrity of our
voting system is just as serious and
important and that has unfortunately
been decimated in the United States and
thus you can make the case that serious
and drastic action is is necessary and
and may in fact be the right thing to do
morally constitutionally and even
legally in some cases although I'm
certainly not holding my breath that
Donald Trump's going to be impeached or
removed because I simply don't think
he's going to be we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today please join me
there become a member at wwg
join pakman.com become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
methods give you access to the bonus
show both support the show and i look
forward to speaking to you then